if you're the GM of the Lakers how do
you fix this year or just fix the team
in general there's not a lot of assets
seems to be Robin Lincoln put together a
pretty shitty roster but you know that's
neither here nor there if you had his
job what would you do differently
it depends on
what my goal was if the goal was to win
like right now if I had to win more
games right right now yeah then you
probably have to make a drastic change
then the DraStic change they probably
have to make it probably people wouldn't
probably even
begin to Fathom what the drive to change
would be
here's how I trade in LeBron
so you would trade LeBron I'm saying I
wouldn't do it you would I wouldn't do
it but you're saying if I was a gym f
my responsibility was to make the team
better right now
how would that make it that means you
have to because you have to get better
players and you can get two to three
players right now so why not trade ad
or you can train A.D
they gotta trade I would think because
from LeBron you probably would get more
for him because
he's LeBron he's going to change the
culture
to your for your organization for the
next
two or three years maybe you have them
yeah I mean he's got a small win I feel
like A.D I think a team should probably
be scared to take A.D because he ain't
played 82 games the last two seasons
right
and you brought up trading LeBron I
would never trade LeBron personally I
call him guard James